I've been using Apple's iPad Mini five
for the last two weeks and I've realized
that it's currently the best tablet on
the market for gaming topping every
Android tablet and iPad for a few
different reasons which I'll get to in
just a minute it's basically the same
iPad as the new iPad air but in a
smaller package the display is much
improved from the iPad Mini 4 with 500
nits of brightness true tone technology
in p3 wide color gamut for incredible
color accuracy for photo editing and it
now supports the Apple pencil for taking
notes drawing and much more
adding tremendous value compared to the
old iPad Mini 4 which is priced at the
same $400 you really get so much more
value with the new iPad Mini 5
especially since you're going from the
a8 processor in the Mini 4 to the a12 in
the Mini 5 which comes directly from the
iPhone 10s and 10's Macs
so you're getting iPhone 10s performance
for only $400 and if you compare it to
the chips you get and the best Android
tablets out there it completely blows
them out of the water and Geekbench for
single core test the iPad Mini 5
basically triples the scores of the
Android tablets and it's the same story
for the multi-core test tripling most of
the scores and almost doubling the score
of the Samsung Galaxy Tab s 4 which
retailed at 780 dollars will has quickly
gone down to five hundred and thirty
dollars still more expensive than the
iPad Mini 5 and finally an N to twos
graphics benchmark which is more
accurate for gaming performance
the iPad Mini 5 again easily outperforms
the Android tablets almost doubling the
score of the Galaxy Tab s 4 and that's
not the only difference
many people know that iPads are more
reliable perform better over time and
hold their value much better than
Android tablets Samsung's $400 Galaxy
Tab s5e is also coming soon and it's
actually packin a similar or slower chip
than the Tab s 4 so the iPad Mini 5 is
going to be the clear winner in terms of
performance for 2019 yes the iPad Mini 5
is more expensive than some of those
Android tablets but trust me you won't
regret spending more the iPad will give
you years of reliable performance but
how is it better than the rest of
Apple's current iPad lineup for starters
the iPad Mini size and weight are
perfect for come
holding in your hand for everything from
browsing the web watching YouTube videos
reading ebooks taking notes drawing
taking it on the go and especially for
gaming the rest of the iPads even the
2018 budget iPad are heavier and much
larger making them less comfortable to
hold for playing games your hands will
get tired over time and you don't really
get that with the iPad Mini 5 it
basically packs all the iPad you'll ever
need in a perfectly compact form factor
now you might be asking why don't I just
get the cheaper 2018 iPad instead well
there are a few drawbacks with that iPad
mainly with the display and I have a
detailed video comparing them if you
want to learn more but there's also a
significant difference in gaming
performance take fortnight for example
the 2018 iPad can only run the game at
30 frames per second on medium graphics
not only that but in game the graphics
are noticeably worse you'll get dropped
frames so it won't be perfectly smooth
and the display is very reflective and
not as bright which can get pretty
annoying
the iPad Mini 5 runs for tonight at 60
frames per second on high settings and
it's incredibly smooth no noticeable
drop frames no issues with reflectivity
and you can play for hours thanks to the
small and light form factor now what
about the 2019 iPad air in 2018 iPad pro
well the iPad air is basically a larger
version of the iPad Mini 5 there's
literally no difference in performance
the 2018 iPad pro is definitely more
powerful than the iPad Mini 5 but is
also twice as expensive it's fairly
large so it's not very comfortable for
long gaming sessions in it's overkill
for basically every game currently
available on the App Store how well in
fortnight is limited to the exact same
graphics settings as the iPad Mini 5 and
it runs it just as smooth with no
benefits at all even with all the extra
performance the story is the same in
other games like asphalt 9 you get 60
frames per second at maxed out graphics
and it runs perfectly smooth on both the
iPad pro and the iPad Mini 5 I also
played some pub G and maxed out the
graphics on both iPads I mean max
everything
HDR since ultra HDR isn't available yet
Ultra framerate anti
enabled in auto-adjust graphics disabled
the iPad pro ran everything perfectly
except it didn't use up the whole
display just like on fortnight there are
black bars all the way around that don't
get used either way I managed to score
the best rating in the game and I won my
first match ever on the iPad Mini 5 it
also ran the game perfectly with maxed
out settings everything was super smooth
no issues at all but it was much more
comfortable to hold in the hand compared
to the iPad pro this time I scored in
ss+
not bad for my first two matches so from
those three graphically demanding games
we can see that the extra power of the
iPad pro isn't really being used
compared to the iPad Mini 5 and until we
get some new and very graphically
demanding games on iOS there won't be
much of a difference in gaming of course
you'll see the difference in tasks like
video editing but the average user
honestly won't be able to tell the
difference in performance and that's why
I'm calling the iPad Mini 5 the best
gaming tablet in 2019 and for only $400
it's a really great deal for what you
get and it'll give you years of reliable
performance for all of your iPad needs
now if the display is too small for your
liking you can pay $100 more for the new
iPad air it's basically the same exact
iPad except with a larger 10.5 inch
display and a smart connector for
Apple's smart keyboard that's it we'll
have links to all the best deals on
these iPads in the video description
below and if you're having trouble
choosing which one to buy click that
button to see our ultimate comparison
guide and hit subscribe for more videos
like this one thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
[Music]